hey 42 here scandinavia
home of pickled herring endless winter
and rain
this ladies and gentlemen is apparently
the happiest place
on earth between 2013 and 2017 the world
happiness report
ranked denmark as the happiest nation on
the planet
and in the 2018 report finland overtook
it
denmark dropped to third place and
norway took the second spot
but the countries that have consistently
topped the charts in
these surveys haven't changed the
scandinavian or more
aptly nordic nations finland
norway denmark iceland are consistently
at the top of the charts
year on year except for sweden
which has remained slightly lower come
on sweden what's the matter
other surveys conducted over more than
20 years have found the same thing
that the vikings at the top of europe
are happier than larry
or should i say olaf and when one
examines nordic life and customs
objectively
it's easy to see why they enjoy one of
the best work-life balances of any
nation
average hours worked per week are
between 35 to 40
and in denmark most jobs permit
employees to work at home at least one
day per week
their work hours are usually flexible
too and if a danish person wants to
leave work early on a friday to go out
drinking with friends
they straight up tell their boss i would
like to leave work at 3pm because
i'm going out with friends this evening
whereas in the uk
or us we might make up some superficial
lie such as i have a dentist appointment
and here lies another reason why
scandinavians
may be so happy they trust
each other the world happiness report
uses different metrics to measure
happiness
such as social security job satisfaction
health freedom generosity of a nation's
citizens
and how much they trust one another
being able to trust your neighbors and
strangers
tends to lead to a happier existence
denmark finland sweden and norway all
rank
in the top 10 for trust alone and it's
easy to see that as nords leave their
doors
unlocked more often than in other places
and they report feeling totally
comfortable
to leave their coat or backpack or even
their baby
unattended in a coffee shop when popping
to the toilet
i dare you to try that in new york or
london and see if your belongings are
there when you get back
and then of course there's social
security a big reason why the nordic
realms consistently
top the happiness charts there's no
doubt that they enjoy some of the best
social services
in the world the oecd lists some
although not all the nordic countries in
the top 10 for healthcare
environment and safety all products of
their heavy welfare states
but my gosh do they pay for it
they have some of the highest personal
income tax rates in the developed world
danes pay 56 to the tax man
but really it's 60 percent when adding
in all a little extras like property tax
the finished a country currently ranked
as the happiest
pay 51 tax but what is astonishing
is how happy scandinavians are about
paying
so much tax when asked 9 out of 10
danes say they are content giving 60
of their money to the government it's
all very well having great public
services
and feeling safe in your own country but
does that
really equate to happiness it's odd to
think of
finland holding the title of the
happiest nation i mean
when was the last time you heard someone
say this year honey i think we should
holiday in helsinki
or perhaps jutland no
people usually opt for destinations such
as france or italy instead
even though neither of those country
ranked particularly high for happiness
parisians could probably expect a rate
in people's coffees
and tourists would still flock there in
their millions
finland is a hostile environment the
temperature in helsinki is almost
always below zero throughout the winter
and it is usually buried under a blanket
of snow
a quarter of finland lapland is within
the arctic circle
and therefore it can be dark all day
long for as many as 50 consecutive days
throughout the year
and most of the country spends half the
year in darkness and majority of the day
anyway
as the sun sets in the early afternoon
throughout the winter
as it's perishingly cold and dark for
half the year it's no wonder that the
finnish
are rather dour people it's not common
that
finns are described as exuberant and
bubbly
they are friendly once you get to know
them don't get me wrong
they just don't go about their day
showing it
usually the opposite in fact they have a
national
word for their shy stoicism sisu
but then it's no wonder when your city
is a black and gray refrigerator
doesn't quite sound like living
conditions that scream happy to me
and the terrible metric rather reflects
that
their suicide rate finland has an
inordinately high suicide rate
it's not the highest in the world as
some people have been led to believe in
fact
it's not even in the top 10. it's
currently ranks number 32
just above the united states with 13.8
suicides per 100 000 people
as of 2016. but surely the reported
happiest nation in the world shouldn't
be near the top end of the scale
furthermore there's a macabre underlying
trend here
the data shows that the higher a country
is ranked
on a variety of happiness indexes the
higher
its suicide rate is there seems to be a
dichotomous positive correlation
between perceived happiness and wanting
to take one's own life
which for obvious reasons makes very
little sense
so perhaps there's something else going
on in denmark and finland
which could throw a shade of doubt on
the results
of happiness surveys and
there could be an aspect of nordic and
especially danish and norwegian culture
that outright rigs the results so that
they will always come on top
no matter what the first issue is how
does one
measure happiness happiness is not
absolute and therefore it's really
difficult to quantify
with statistics happiness is an umbrella
term that encompasses a range of
positive emotions such as
joy contentment well-being success
and safety if you were to hand out an
award for the people who
seem the happiest on the surface we
would surely give it
to a south american country the gallup
emotions report
ranks countries based on the negativity
or positivity of their emotions
such as how often they cry frown smile
and
laugh the results the smiliest
most emotionally positive nation in the
world
is paraguay every year latin american
countries
dominate this poll colombia el salvador
guatemala costa rica
ecuador and honduras are all
consistently
in the top ten also every year canada
ranks highly somewhere amongst the latin
countries but that's no surprise it
seems canadians
really do live up to their reputation
but as we all know
there's a lot more to happiness than
positive emotions
as maslow illustrated in his hierarchy
of needs there are other requisites
humans need
to feel happy such as safety friendship
food and housing it's on these
other metrics on which the south
american nations fall down they may be
smiley
but they have the highest homicide rates
in the world whereas the nordic
countries
host some of the wealthiest citizens in
the world and are some of the safest
and most secure places to live
especially norway with an average gdp
per capita of over 70 thousand dollars
mostly because of its oil wealth
off the back of the immense wealth that
the nordic region has been able to
generate
over the past few decades they have all
been able to fund
the world's most prolific social welfare
systems
every need is taken care of so much so
in fact that the scandinavians
are statistically some of the worst
savers in the world
because there is an inbuilt assumption
that the state will take care of them
the heavy welfare providing governments
in denmark norway
finland iceland and sweden means that
the people
are content but that is precisely the
issue
that fools happiness surveys into a
false sense
of nordic security scandinavians
are happy about just being content
scandinavians are the kings of
self-affacement it's a huge social
faux pas in nordic countries to brag
about your income or material
possessions
it is considered wrong to even desire
material possessions
even if one can afford them and most
notes definitely can
scandinavians all take part in a huge
daily game of who can lift the most
frugally
hugely and who can pay the most tax
you see scandinavians live by a set of
strict unspoken
laws they aren't real laws but a set of
social etiquette rules come ideology
by which almost every nord lives they
call it yantalovan
it originates from norway but it's
followed by all the nordic countries
yantalovan or the law of yanta dictates
that one should put society
before their own personal needs and
desires
one should never boast about their
accomplishments or material possessions
and one must never be jealous of another
in fact there are actually 10 written
and widely disseminated commandments of
yantalovan
including you're not to think you are
anything special
and you're not to think you are good at
anything to put it simply one should be
content
with what they have and nothing more
that is the lore of yanta
it's more than just a national
stereotype like the british love
queueing
yantalovan is an ideology that has
become indoctrinated
into the scandi youth and thus is firmly
woven into the fabric of nordic society
the antilovan is pretty much the polar
opposite
of the individualist way we live in the
us uk
and most other western capitalist
societies where we always desire bigger
houses and more premium cars than our
neighbors
contrary to popular belief all the
scandinavian countries
are not socialist they are unarguably
free
market capitalist societies but they are
underpinned
by a collectivist mentality neither of
these contradictory
ways of living is necessarily any better
than the other
there are pros and cons of living within
both of these ideological frameworks
they are just different and this huge
culture
gap between the us and scandinavia also
goes a long way to explain why a scandi
economic model
could never work in the u.s but that's a
topic for another time
it's exactly this difference however
that explains why the nordic countries
are consistently reported
as the happiest because scandinavians
are on the whole
extremely content and they don't desire
much
their bar for happiness is far lower
than other ethnic groups
and in a way that's a really nice thing
but it also explains how a far higher
percentage of
nordic folk may report being happy
compared to those in other countries
yanta law
also affects many other criteria by
which we rate our personal satisfaction
take housing the antelope dictates that
a norwegian
shouldn't desire larger houses than
their peers
so when asked they are bound to say that
they are satisfied
with their modest households whereas an
american living in an identical house to
the norwegian
may deem that house far too small or
inadequate
and thus have a lower level of life
satisfaction because americans are
brought up to believe in the american
dream
practically the opposite of the antelope
which suppresses the potential greatness
of an individual
therefore all these surveys that
reportedly place the scandinavian
countries
at the top of the happiness league
tables may have
overlooked the fact that scandinavian
culture favors
selfless contentedness over selfish
and hedonistic happiness i may not have
met
every dane and finn in the world but in
my experience they are no friendlier
or happier than the british or americans
they're simply more content with less
and that's absolutely fine furthermore
there is a self-perpetuating trend for
danes and finns to report
greater levels of happiness than they
actually feel
the danes in particular are extremely
patriotic people
good on them they have a lot to be proud
of but as part of their patriotism
danes are now well aware of their
reputation as one of the happiest
nations in the world
this causes danes to report higher
satisfaction scores than they may
otherwise
also it's in the very nature of nordic
culture to not admit when one is unhappy
after all that would be putting one's
own needs before the collective mass
scandinavians are more likely to report
happiness
even if they are unhappy due to the
social conditioning
of their own culture the sisu mentality
in finland i spoke about earlier
has a lot to do with this as well and
the nordic happiness bubble
may be coming to an end mental health
issues are on a steep rise across the
region
norway has seen a 40 increase in
reported mental health issues
in young people over a five-year period
and over recent years
vastly increased immigration into the
region is threatening the previously
high
ethnic and cultural homogeneity of all
the nordic countries
after all it is this shared culture that
provides these countries with their
close
social bonds etiquette and high levels
of trust
in their communities all these
attributes create
happy communities erode those values by
introducing other cultures
and we may start to see a shift in the
satisfaction levels
of the nordic people research has shown
that ethnic minorities living in denmark
and sweden
are the least happy people in the
country
and i'm not exclusively talking about
eastern immigrants those statistics
include white expats because they don't
share the same culture they don't
believe in yantalor
or fully understand the weird pleasure
of hygge
scandinavian countries want to think of
themselves as the most inclusive in the
world
but they have such strong cultures that
the truth is
wide scale inclusion of others may never
be
possible without sacrificing the very
culture that makes them who they are and
makes them so happy whilst it's
interesting to analyze
ultimately we shouldn't judge the
happiness of nations based on surveys
and various data points
because happiness means something
entirely different to everyone
the best way to find out if a nation is
full of happy people is by visiting and
spending time with those people
even then you may not get their unique
breed of happiness
because you're simply unable to
understand their bizarre culture and
customs
but that doesn't mean that they aren't
happy the world
is too diverse to say that any one
country has a monopoly
on happiness thanks for watching
do you know what would make me happy if
you check out my new book which i'm
crowdfunding over on unbound
if you haven't already watched a launch
video then head over to unbound by
clicking the link in the description
and pledge today to get your signed
first edition copy
thank you